[Applause]
okay here are the questions George will
what do you think of Bernie Sanders
taking up the mantle of FDR in defense
of democratic socialism
what he said was comes under the rubric
of plagiarism it's the it's a clear
Restatement of tepid tweaking of the
State of the Union address Roosevelt
gave in 1944 so the wave of the future
turns out to be 75 years ago
[Laughter]
Eliot what are your thoughts on New York
law that would allow Congress to access
Trump's tax returns look I am all for I
think that a state can determine when
its own tax returns should and should
not be public I think it's an
embarrassment that somebody would be the
president without releasing them any
public official in New York these days
does as a matter of course New York
should pass the law and see what happens
okay what do you mean that shows over
when did you when do you remove to HBO
[Laughter]
we're doing this on Twitter now oh good
but we are on face now I know think
we're on YouTube what the [ __ ]
we're on the toilet that's what you are
Martin Short what do you think of Canada
and the European Union's plan to ban
single-use plastics by 2021 no you're
against it I'm sure for it III never
understand why brilliant ideas take 15
20 30 years well I mean California has
basically the same thing pending but
even if we pass it not till 2030 really
California progressive California seat
of the resistance you can't do better
but this was America and George here
mister why is America like I for one
that I can't get up we built the Empire
State Building and the depression share
110 days have built these average
dependence during wartime in 16 months
you can't get the yes you can't
negotiate the environmental and racial
set-asides in 15 months now during World
War two
did we not ban cars I mean stop building
cars except for military uses all the
car fat can you imagine doing that today
that kind of sacrifice that kind of
mobilization saying okay no more cars no
you know what we need the factories for
planes and tanks no more cars bill this
will come from a nice liberal Democrat
sometimes there's too much due process I
think George would agree that there's
too much due process nothing important
gets done because everybody has a way of
stopping things that are important and
too much great petty regulation a great
New Yorker Senator Pat Moore and I had
one of my very best friends America used
to be a society that rewarded people who
did things now we reward people who stop
them right I've always said I'm immortal
do I have any more questions for me I
[Music]
mean I've been layin things I could ask
you no no I want to go to your prepared
strumming feet
Barry Weiss will the protestors against
Hong Kong's proposed extradition bill be
successful I don't know if they'll be
successful but the fact what's going on
has been taken to the streets to defend
democracy against I mean it's a
complicated situation but but
essentially defending democracy against
gee and China and the fact that no one
here seems to care about it that the
President of the United States who's
supposed to be the leader of the free
world to my knowledge has said nothing
in support of those peaceful protesters
it's a Shanda as we say an ich it's
ridiculous gee whiz let me see it is
fascinating to me it's not about
trumping it who cares about Trump Trump
is the con man he was voted for Democrat
most of his life it's everyone else
that's what's right the enablers the
ones that will be judged Mitch McConnell
history in the most depressing way yeah
Mitch McConnell who listen he not only
is confusing but this is a man who in
his entire life never took a good
picture
because
I actually think what's going on Hong
Kong is a remarkably affirmative
wonderful thing it because it is maybe
the first sign that China is being seen
for what it is which is one of the most
repressive autocratic regimes in the
world and I think it's about time people
saw that and I think what's going on
Hong Kong is great they're not gonna win
and so here's gonna be another defeat
for democracy you know here we are in
2019 and democracy is in retreat all
over the world there's organic
opposition which is a wonderful thing it
will succeed in the long run we like
everything organic here now I read that
you turned down the part in dumb and
dumber
now I never saw the movie because I
didn't want to ruin the book you did you
could have been the Jim Carrey - all it
was I read the scripts I thought this is
too highbrow
what a shame I know I wouldn't be here
with you people all actors have one of
those at least one an absolute Reynolds
has like 10 every great movie in that
you could be in The Godfather you'd be
in 3 days of the Condor you can be in
the nope I want to do significant ball
[Laughter]
George we'll do you believe the
expanding powers of the presidency can
ever be reversed yes I think the physics
of our politics is at work now this is
the optimistic view which is that
Congress it turns out can be embarrassed
and the president can now that
progressives who created the modern
presidency have seen that they're not
always going to occupy the modern
presidency they're going to rethink the
separation of powers which they began to
undermine when Woodrow Wilson became the
first president to criticize the
American Founding because largely of the
separation of powers but they but they
don't want it when when Obama was being
taunted by the Republicans about Syria
remember this and he said you know what
I'll go into Syria
give me authorization it's your job it's
in the Constitution and they of course
were like no because then if it goes
badly were to blame but he went into
Libya without anybody's worth well sure
but it's more likely to happen on
domestic policies where the Democratic
Congress is gonna try to restrain Trump
and regret that it gave President Obama
all the powers he had reports are gonna
do the same thing Charlie what do you
anticipate the first round of democratic
debates to reveal about the candidates
oh yes we didn't really mention that
tonight we popped it up this way they
got the first two nights twenty people I
don't even know some of them are wait
for that so she literally did right
she's like a new-age well but marianne
williamson is one of the reasons why God
invented the mute button
these debates go on they're good they're
gonna have the greatest candidates and
people are gonna go you know cute for
this person you never dollars and you do
not so you might be doing something
that's right you know some of these
people who were we do know who is not
going to be president who are not gonna
say anything right but Andrew yang I
mean that that's it out-of-the-box
choice and way out of the box he's doing
quite well you know Trump I might say
everybody thought he wouldn't go
anywhere I said he was so listen to me
what about how bad do you feel if you're
one of the three who didn't make the cut
of twenty this is like not getting a
rose on the first night at the governor
of Montana who has rights has might have
something to say that right would be
interested in because he's a Democrat
who wins in a Republican state and
instead we have to listen to I'm sorry
you know marianne williamson Iowa is so
small twenty candidates they can meet
everybody six months from now when these
crisis happens oh you have no idea today
what's gonna happen and despite all the
pundits we're gonna tell us what's gonna
happen they have no idea who do you
think if you had to bet now your own
money who's gonna win the nomination my
own money that seems very unfair I'm
gonna say Biden because because the
Democrats gonna be too afraid to go with
somebody who might lose to Donald you're
with at a certain point you didn't have
the panic set in you think it's gonna be
Biden I think at this point people are
in politics at an active in the
nominating electorate because politics
is fun I think the most fun candidate
for Democrats is Elizabeth Warren I
think when you talk about when you talk
about these debates he is incapable of
anything coming out of his mouth that is
an impressive I think he's going to be
phenomenal on television and I think
he'll then do a lot of
he'll be everywhere and I think if the
Millennials would actually vote if your
18:37 seems pretty old right it could be
Trump it's gonna be the dirtiest
election ever I mean no matter who would
it you know Trump is like an old series
that you like the first half season I'm
telling you people will get bored
I think he's shtick is wearing thinner
well it already has and he's down in the
polls yeah we'll see all right thank you
very much everybody
[Applause]
you